so Jamie Lannister
someone forgot to write down all your
great deeds but still time is there for
a forty-year-old night with one hand how
can you protect me with that I used my
left hand now your grace makes for more
of a contest
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video today I wanted to
talk about Sir Jaime Lannister and how I
think his story is going to end next
season as you can see from the clip I
showed at the beginning of this video I
want to discuss a few different things I
think Jaime can do that can help him be
remembered as someone that did something
good for the realm instead of just being
known as the Kingslayer which is a title
he has held for nearly two decades
Jaime does not want to only be
remembered as the man who murdered the
king he swore an oath to protect
personally I did think Jaime made the
right choice when he killed the Mad King
but it's never gonna be seen as
something honorable in the eyes of
others besides maybe Brienne because she
did seem to believe his story about what
really happened that day but I do have a
couple different ideas for Jaime's
character going in a season a actually
one of the ideas I have could kill a few
different birds with one stone now
hopefully I can explain all of this in a
way that actually makes some sense in my
opinion I still think Jaime is destined
for some greatness because we have seen
the way Jaime's character has been
progressing over the years and I think
he will be a completely different person
by the time this show ends at the
beginning of this series Jaime was one
of the most hated characters in all of
Westeros he was blinded by his own love
for his sister that drove him to do just
about anything to make sure no one ever
came between them as we saw on the very
first episode Jaime was willing to kill
brain stark just to silence him that way
no one knew Jaime was sleeping with his
own sister who was also the King's wife
Jaime even said later on that he would
kill anyone for Cersei which was pretty
obvious at the time but so much has
happened since then and slowly Jaime has
started to change a little bit although
he was still deeply in love with his
sister but now that Jaime has abandoned
Cersei I don't think there is no turning
back for Jaime
I don't think Jaime's ever gonna allow
Cersei to influence or manipulate him
again and this will set Jaime on a path
of redemption and in the end I think
Jaime will be remembered as a man who
ended up doing what was right for
everyone instead of just his own selfish
needs or his family's
I think many people believe Jamie
Lannister will end up being the one to
kill Cersei Lannister and the way things
are looking right now I think that is a
very strong possibility as well but I
also think I know a way they can do this
that would actually make some sense and
it would also repeat history in a few
different ways which this story does
tend to do as of right now Jaime
Lannister is on his way north to live up
to his end of the deal by helping Jon
and Daenerys fight the army of the Dead
during the dragonpit scene Cersei said
they would help the north in this great
war but as we all know Cersei never
intended on helping them because she
wants the dead to help take out her
enemies for her this made Jaime sick to
his stomach because he knows they have
no chance of winning any war against the
army of the Dead or the Dragons if they
don't have any alliances even with the
help of the golden company coming over
to Westeros Jaime still wants no part of
Circe's plan Jaime wants to keep his
word by going north and helping John and
Daenerys but there is going to come a
time when Cersei is going to need to be
dealt with someone must put an end to
her reign but we all know Cersei if they
won her off the Iron Throne they're
gonna have to rip it from her cold dead
hands and that may be exactly what
someone is gonna have to do you're on
Greyjoy is currently on his way to pick
up the goating company then he has to
return to King's Landing but I think
Cersei is gonna be in for a big surprise
when she realizes the golden company
want nothing to do with her
and once Cersei realizes she has no
chance of winning the war against Jon
and Daenerys she's gonna do anything in
her power to make sure no one rules
King's Landing and this is where I think
Jaime Lannister will come into play the
first problem Cersei is gonna face is
gonna be with the golden company the
golden company actually has a reputation
for never breaking a contract this is
one of the reasons why they are so
expensive in the first place but the
wall also had a reputation for never
falling either and we all saw how that
ended even though the golden company is
known for never breaking a contract they
actually have broke a contract before in
the books instead of honoring their
contract they decided to sail to
Westeros with a character that many
people believed was Aegon Targaryen so
now that Jon Snow's real name was
revealed to be a gan Targaryen there is
a chance something very similar could
happen during next season the golden
company could definitely break their
contract with
a Lannister by helping the Targaryen
during the Great War and this would also
back Cersei into a corner and leaving
herself with no choice but to turn
King's Landing into a ticking time bomb
just like the Mad King Aerys Targaryen
did but this is what I think Jaime will
use this as an opportunity to seize
King's Landing and kill Cersei I think
history is going to repeat itself and
there's going to be a similar situation
to what happened during Robert's
rebellion Tywin Lannister was the hand
of the king for the Mad King for 20
years but Tywin gave up the position
after the Mad King made Jaime Lannister
a member of his Kingsguard Tywin
actually wanted Jaime to carry on his
legacy but when the Mad King made him a
member of the Kingsguard this stripped
Jaime of having any chance of having a
family and inheriting any lands or
titles so this pissed I went off and he
went back to Casterly Rock
during Robert's rebellion Tywin
basically stayed out of it until the
right opportunity arose when Robert
Baratheon killed Rhaegar on the Trident
this made the rest of regards army
retreat which gave Robert and Ned a
clear path to King's Landing in order to
remove the Mad King from power when
Tywin Lannister heard about Rhaegar
dying during the battle he knew the war
was about to be over
so he gathered up his men and he headed
for the gates of King's Landing
when the Mad King realized he was about
to lose the war he had his Pyromancer
place wildfire all over the city
that way he could blow it up before ever
having to step down his King once Tywin
reached the gates of King's Landing he
tricked the Mad King into letting him
and his men into the city so instead of
Tywin helping the Mad King he decided to
prove his loyalty to Robert Baratheon
instead so he ordered the mountain to
kill Rhaegar wife and their children the
Mad King realized his time was about to
be up so he sent his Pyromancer to set
the city on fire but when Jaime realized
what was happening he killed the
Pyromancer before he can light the
Wildfire then he killed the Mad King
when Cersei realizes the golden company
broke their contracts she's gonna have
no choice but to do the same thing the
Mad King was gonna do we all know Cersei
is not gonna bend the knee or one to
Casterly Rock
she already proved she was willing to
blow up the city once before and once
she realizes she has no one left at her
side she's gonna do the same thing again
but this time she will make sure
the entire city can blow up and once
again Qyburn is going to be her
Pyromancer the show has already hinted
at a big battle taking place in King's
Landing when they showed the Great Hall
completely destroyed but Jamie will
intervene just like he did during
Robert's rebellion when Cersei puts the
city on lockdown I think Jamie's gonna
do exactly what his father did when the
Mad King was ruling King's Landing Jamie
will arrive outside the gate and get
word to Cersei that he is here to help
at this point sir she's gonna be
extremely desperate and still having
feelings for Jaime she's gonna allow him
to enter the city but Jamie's not gonna
be there to help this time he's gonna be
there to stop her and Qyburn before they
blow up the city once Jamie gets through
the gates he's gonna kill Qyburn just
like he did with the Pyromancer during
the mad Kings reign then Jamie will kill
Cersei history will repeat once again
and Jamie will have use Tywin's trick to
gain access to the city then Jamie will
kill a mad Roller once again saving the
city and its people from complete
destruction by fulfilling the valonqar
prophecy at the same time Jamie's pages
in the white book will be filled with
tales of how he saved the people of
King's Landing from burning by wildfire
for the second time he will no longer be
known as the Kingslayer but instead the
savior of King's Landing comment down
below and let me know what you think
personally I think this would be a
really cool way to end Circe's reign and
it would be a fitting ending for Jaime
Lannister story arc if Jamie doesn't do
something like that then I think he may
end up sacrificing himself by saving one
of the stark children he has also been
connected to brain stark since the
beginning of this story - since Jamie
tried to kill bran by pushing him out
the window I think he could also redeem
himself by saving or protecting the
Starks and if he would happen to die in
the process I think Brienne would be the
one to make sure Jaime is remembered as
a hero and not just some Kingslayer I
would actually be happy with either one
of those endings Jaime saving King's
Landing would be really cool or saving
one of the Starks would be cool too it
would end his story on a positive note
and it would be a complete 180 from the
person we met during season 1 but put
your thoughts opinions and questions
down below let me know what your
thoughts are for Jaime Lannister's
endgame what can he do that makes the
most sense for you thanks for stopping
by once again to watch
the video really do appreciate that and
I also want to thank all of my patreon
supporters as well I hope you all have a
great day I'll see you in the next one
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]